well good afternoon everyone
um as you can see I've just landed in
Israel at what is a pivotal moment I'm
very much looking forward to getting
into my discussions but I just want it
all for a few words immediately upon
Landing
on Shabbat Jews around the world
recite the matovu
part of that prayer reads
your great love inspires me to enter
your house
to Worship in your holy sanctuary
filled with awe for you
I love your house
seven people were killed in Friday's
terrorist attack
many more were wounded
most were leaving a synagogue after
prayer
to the families of the victims
we express our most heartfelt
condolences knowing that we can never
know
the depth of your loss
May the memory of your loved ones be a
blessing
to take an innocent life in an act of
terrorism is always
a heinous crime
but to Target people outside their place
of worship
is especially shocking
for every faith the house of worship is
hallowed
it's a place of communion
of all
and as natova reminds us
of love
so Friday's attack was
more than an attack on individuals
it was also an attack on the universal
Act
of practicing one's faith
we condemn it in the strongest terms
we also condemn the subsequent terrorist
attack in Jerusalem on Saturday in which
a father and son were wounded
and we condemn all those who celebrate
these and any other acts of terrorism
that take innocent lives
no matter who the victim is
or what they believe
calls for vengeance against more
innocent victims are not the answer
and acts the retaliatory violence
against civilians are never Justified
it's the responsibility of everyone
to take steps to calm tensions rather
than inflame them
to work toward a day when people no
longer feel afraid in their communities
in their homes in their places of
worship
that is the only way to Halt the rising
tide of violence that has taken too many
lives too many Israelis too many
Palestinians
I'll make that clear throughout my time
in Israel on the West Bank with everyone
that I meet
Friday's attack occurred on
International Holocaust Remembrance Day
a day when we mourn The Six Million Jews
killed in the showa and dedicate
ourselves Anew to rooting out the hatred
and dehumanization
that may such unspeakable crimes
possible
to ensure that history never repeats
itself
all of us must recommit to that
responsibility
we will not shrink from it
we will rise to meet it
thank you